did you know that every day on average
2,000 pupils have been excluded from
school and 40 which are permanent this
week saw the much-delayed publication of
the Timpson reports looking in see said
exclusions one of the reports key
recommendations is that schools
maintained some accountability for the
pupils they have permanently excluded
and I couldn't agree more
whilst nobody wants a kid creating
carnage in the classroom the solution
can't simply be to kick them out of the
whole education process especially not
if the reason is just to protect the
scores results in the league tables all
kids learn differently and most trouble
kids have reasons to be that way of
which given care support and guidance
can often soon be ironed out joined up
accountability needs to take place
between the schools and the council's to
ensure that exclusion from school
doesn't mean exclusion from education
[Music]
well Michelle a second time today I'm
gonna say I entirely agree with you yeah
and I'm so glad you raised this topic I
debated it over the weekend on my ABC
show and actually I called it a racket
the notion of Headmaster's offloading
children with either learning
difficulties or other challenges and
that could range from poverty and hunger
or sleep deprivation because they're
sleeping in the same bedroom as toddlers
and babies because they're crammed into
a small house so they don't get a good
night's sleep they turn up a class and
they fall asleep the teacher may think
they're lazy when actually they're just
unable to sleep at home and and you know
hunger is another one where they come in
hungry so they're unable to concentrate
pupil poverty so a practice has
developed as their as the government
report rightfully identified of
offloading which is a headmaster
excluding these challenged pupils from
the school just to maintain a certain
level in the league tables I think what
you're doing there is you're for
essentially beans off roll grunting
sorry it isn't offload but it's known as
off-roading you're absolutely right I
think what you're doing there is for
business reasons
you are basically permanently affecting
the future education and therefore
career prospects of a vulnerable young
child yeah and they are often children
thirteen year olds 14 year olds and then
of course what happens once they off
rolled
is they get sent to the PR use the pupil
Referral Units and at the PR use that's
where gangs are waiting at the gates
preying on these vulnerable school kids
knowing that when they go to these PR
use they don't know anybody inside
they're often scared because they're
quite violent places they can be P I use
and so the gangs then offer them
protection and then get involved in get
them involved in drugs gangs and dealing
and that's it the future of that child
is gone it's not just for my exclusions
which are a huge problem but what the
data police doesn't capture is informal
exclusions you know I've reported on so
many cases where a teacher will say your
child can only come in three hours a
week and there are ways of getting
around since that doesn't get recorded
as a delusion and they say we can't cope
with your child they can come in twice a
week for one lesson and there are so
many parents who and then the part of
the story haven't really talked about is
how many of these children who are being
offered educational homes and children
of color
it's shocking the only where I would
kind of dispute your angle majid of
thought I think I do think her teachers
need to be held accountable but for me
this is much more of a systemic issue if
you look at the pressure that's been put
on schools especially academies
academies ation has increased these
market pressures on schools they are
under relentless pressure to prove
results they feel they cannot afford to
have disruptive children or children who
are low performing academically and they
are therefore resorting these completely
unethical methods of hiding these
children from the system but I don't
think this is a question just of heads
not being good people this is a question
of the system that is great of this
pressure on school what are you gonna do
with naughty boys in school this isn't
just about no no no but what are you
going to do with naughty boys once again
to the root of why a child is just
naughty well a lot of these children
have learning difficulties anyone but
I'm saying when you have a majority of
children being excluded having
diagnosable special educational needs
that can be treated given time care
there's way too many and as you quite
right off rolling as it is a hideous
practice and there probably is an
argument to make sure that these
children's education is then reflected
in the league tables but let's say
there's a class of 32 and 30 or 31
children aren't getting educated because
one is just being continually naughty no
educational needs no you've got to kick
him out
that's not really what we're talking
about and I used to be that night kid
and I was constantly kicked out of class
but that we're not really talking about
that we're talking about
you're totally 7720 are all people who
have special needs or whatever people in
prison as we know are people that as
children had special needs
we know that the literacy levels of
that's not the point thirty months or
dad's the point is is back to at West
Point we're not doing enough to equip
the schools with the tools they need to
actually be able to help these children
we know that crews are a pipeline to
prison so they're not working well it
would say that a thirteen-year-old
because the sort of thing you get
excluded for well at least in my day
would be if you have a fight with a
teacher right a thirteen-year-old having
a fistfight with a teacher I'd say that
by definition they have certain
challenges and problems either at home
or mental health or something because
it's not normal for the
thirteen-year-old to throw fists at a
teacher an X it can be kicked out of
school right well sort of his teacher
you agree with me he's kicked out of
school depending on what hell because
example there are other options for
example you have special needs classes
within the same school right so it
depends on what the problem is if that
thirteen Robin is subsequently found
surely you'd agree with me here if there
subsequently found to be beaten up by
the father every night then there are
certain other measures that can be taken
first so he said you're gonna back into
the arms of that grown man or woman goes
to school thinking that the thirty might
hit him or her again that's this is I'm
not saying don't ever exclude a kid ever
again that's not what I'm suggesting so
if I've got a kid in a classroom and
battering his teacher of course you
shouldn't just be said oh yeah carry on
keep going one suggesting that for a
second it would make me an idiot
what I'm suggesting is that X been
excluded from this school shouldn't then
mean that they just drop kicks over
there and it's forgotten about yeah and
this is my theory so what I'm saying is
because we have this obsession and
parents in some ways it's blame for this
because they are obsessed when choosing
a school for their child what are the
results of this school so we have this
society it's obsessed with the academic
output of a school and we've got schools
for that were even risk having those
affected by some kid that's messing
around and that's what's driving all of
this obsession with academics and also
because at the moment if a school off
rolls this child then that failing child
doesn't have an impact on the results
whereas what Michele is saying is we
have failing child's and if that failure
is performance still has an impact then
the score is going to actually want to
do something referral unit that's very
impersonal you know that yes goals could
be doing more about this debate Nick in
particular your angle is that this isn't
mysterious there are professionals who
know exactly how to help children who
disrupting class you talk to educational
psychologists they know exactly what you
do they have the resources that our
class sizes such that there is lip space
all the time so that and that's if you
talk to her teachers who are doing this
off rolling yeah talk to them off the
record they will tell you we could help
this child if we didn't have a chronic
shortage one educational psychology
comes in for one hour a week cuts to
social services cuts to child adolescent
mental health services the whole system
is breaking down and it's these
vulnerable children who pay the price
and I'm I don't think it's fair for the
other thirty children in the class what
they're interested in disrupt that I'm
saying that school is also the place
where you should be able to help the
child that is struggling not prune not
prison and excluding them is just a way
of going to disappear the problem and
it's our responsibility as a society to
include these children in the mainstream
and if we're not doing it we are failing
as a society let's not make it so easy
for the schools to exclude all this
happy clappy bull bleep will you just
accept some kids are naughty and need to
be bitter is there a reason usually
behind naughty behavior in your view for
children connected with the lessons well
they just like being the class clown or
whatever it might be and in some cases
they've got real problems yeah there
might be dyslexia but if they don't
usually they need help gluto for just
being a class clown though would you
know tell all the clowning goats you
always talk about the power of good
teachers yes therefore we know the right
teacher can save any child and that
Palmerston most I would say anyway